he's Jim Harbaugh the michigan head
coach you can check out the Super Bowl
special edition of attack each day it's
Harbaugh podcast out tomorrow get new
episodes every Tuesday at podcast one
calm the podcast one app and Apple
podcast Continental Tire coaches corner
and we welcome in Jim Harbaugh coach how
are you this morning
I'm doing good Dan how are you I'm doing
okay a little tired but man that had a
lot of excitement last night
where'd you watch the game last night
you watch the game in my mom and dad and
watched all your stuff with brother John
on the set you guys did a phenomenal job
he was great specialist yeah it's been a
long day for you yeah yep long day but
your brother did great and had some fun
and you know I love the fact that he
wanted to be great
you know throughout the day he kept
saying you know just tell me tell me
what I need and he's coachable I don't
know if you are but I know that that
John is coachable Jim
he definitely is he texted we were
texting a little bit we're tell him how
great he was doing and he was very
complimentary of you and everybody that
was on your team very very professional
was the word he used and he was very
very impressed what do you make of what
happened yesterday where you want to
start was there a key play a turning
point that stood out to you I think the
place to start is wow that was a
wonderful wonderful great great game a
credit to football is when I turned off
that set that's what I mean I thought I
thought all involved players coaches I
was a magnificent football game the
Patriots defense where they had been
playing well but it felt like they never
got any kind of rhythm I know Malcolm
Butler got benched here but how
surprised were you that the Eagles were
that good offensively considering Nick
Foles is in there not Carson Wentz I
thought both offenses were tremendous I
mean great game plans on both sides josh
mcdaniels deserves a lot of credit
play calling was was outstanding I
thought the offenses were were able to
keep the defense's off balance with
their play calling and the quarterbacks
were were tremendous I mean did they
miss a throw maybe maybe one or two but
the the accuracy of the throws the the
catches have been they're worried
there weren't he drops it was just just
unbelievable I thought else on Jeffries
I mean he was he was tremendous I mean
it was just you go right down the line
and I thought this both teams the the
other thing that stood out was the the
energy the fitness that both teams had
neither team I mean they were playing
all all concern were playing great in
the fourth quarter and throughout the
game it was several things stood out
there was just plus plus plus four for
the game of football I don't know if
Doug Peterson is factoring in Brady but
he wasn't he wasn't afraid to go on
fourth down and there were a couple of
them you know there was fourth and goal
when you got the touchdown with Foles
also with what five minutes to go he has
the fourth down pass to Zach heard is I
mean there's two ways to look at you're
really confident in your offense and he
was he was not afraid to go on fourth
down during the regular season but also
you don't want to give the ball back to
Tom Brady and it felt like that factored
in on that that final fourth down call
that they had with five minutes to go
is that how you saw that as a coach yeah
yeah they were trailing at the time and
they go for fourth and one is they ran a
they ran a mess play they ran they
picked beautifully Zach Ertz on the
crossing around you could see the pick
play and it was well executed wasn't you
know wasn't called as a penalty but that
was a that was a huge play of the game
talking to Jim Harbaugh he's got a
podcast that comes out every Tuesday
it's called attack each day the
Harbaugh's podcast and I say plural
because his father is part of that and
it's out tomorrow
every Tuesday podcast 1.com the podcast
one amp and Apple podcast also when you
have this
coaching mentality there when you have
foals it didn't feel like they were
shrinking the playbook on him it felt
like they were saying hey go out and go
to hell you're right right yeah no doubt
I mean that you took the words right out
of my mouth I was just thinking that my
head as I was watching the game and just
now I mean the amount of offense that
was in that the Eagles had and the
Patriots head in the game it was it was
a big volume and it was all executed
well I mean the no pre-snap penalties
know very few post snap penalties you it
appeared like there was very few mental
mistakes I mean they were they were
tightened in all areas you didn't and
you didn't see any any blown coverages
[Music]
offensively no oh they weren't on the
same page they were it was really tight
both teams were outstanding that way and
then the quarterbacks and receivers were
making the tight throws making the
making the tough catches it was it was
really phenomenal they just a marvelous
from an execution standpoint I I thought
on all all sides offense defense both
teams early it was it was that great of
a game are you and your parents kitchen
right now no I'm at the office oh we're
you know we're in your backyard for our
football back at work I think you know
there's a there's gonna be a lot to
watch and really you'll see a lot of a
lot of coaches that will be watching
this game there you had the RPO factor
how do the out of the Patriots attempt
to defense you know that scheme I don't
know how many run pass options or there
were in the game by Philadelphia I'd be
interested in knowing that you know
exactly we'll study that didn't maybe
maybe a dozen throughout the game and
always talked a lot by by your crew and
from a coaching standpoint so I want to
say okay to the Patriots with with two
weeks to
you know defend that how would they
defend it what was their what was their
approach but I don't know I didn't
couldn't tell how many rpoS Philadelphia
actually run but I would say it would be
between six and twelve of what I could
just see on television but you know the
off balance nature I mean Philadelphia
does a tremendous job of mixing their
calls they had a lot a lot of volume in
their in their offense and and again
just extremely impressed with how how
well they executed Doug Peterson
phenomenal play calling and Frank Reich
deserves a ton of credit as the
offensive coordinator John Dee Philippa
the quarterback coach I mean a
tremendous job starting quarterback gets
hurt Nick Foles I mean that story's just
just awesome and you know right on down
the line I'm watching the guys that that
I've coached and know on both sides of
the team like km fleming and johnson
bottom OC and Zach Ertz and the michigan
guys Brandon Graham and Tom Brady played
you know play great it was it was an
enjoyable game to watch you know just a
credit to football enjoy the off season
please tell your father we said a low
and always great to catch up with you
Jim always a pleasure Dan thank you all
right let's Jim Harbaugh a special
edition of attack the day the Harbaugh
podcast love is dead out tomorrow
podcast one con tiempo you think every
the Harbaugh family their last night
watching the game Jim Harbaugh and his
dad big dad Forbes and every commercial
break back let's arm-wrestle you know
then the next break little slapbox you
know and then they just go out in the
backyard hit each other it sticks for an
hour they probably breaking down plays -
he's probably got a chalkboard a
whiteboard yeah chalkboard they're tire
Coach's Corner Continental Tire proud to
be the exclusive tire of the Dan Patrick
show no matter where you are what you
drive how you drive Continental designs
tires for what you do for more
information visit Continental Tire com
Continental Tire for what do you do for
more Dan Patrick show to the
it's channel 239 on DirecTV or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]